REDUCED THE WALL BETWEEN CHURCH
AND STATE.
>> THAT IS A BEATABLE THING TO
BEHOLD.
20 ME NOW IS ERIC SCHMITT AND
TEXAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN
PATRICK.
YOU FILED A BRIEF.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE PEOPLE
THINK THAT THIS DECISION IS A
SEPARATION OF CHURCH AND STATE
ISSUE?
>> Attorney General Schmitt: THE
SE PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS
AND THEIR OBJECTION IS WITH THE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON THE
IDEA THAT PEOPLE COULD EXPRESS
THEIR RELIGIOUS BELIEFS AND THE
GOVERNMENT WILL PROTECT THAT
RIGHT TRACK GOD-GIVEN RIGHT NOT
INFRINGE UPON IT.
AND SO HERE YOU HAVE A COACH
ENGAGED IN VOLUNTARY PRAYER AND
THE LEFT HAS LOST THEIR MIND.
WE ARE LED TO THE BELIEF THAT IT
IS PERFECTLY OKAY TO FORCE THEIR
KIDS TO SIT THROUGH DRAG QUEEN
STORY OUR IN THIS BOOK
INDOCTRINATION OF OUR SCHOOLS
BUT THEY ARE OKAY WITH THAT.
THEY WANT TO PUT STEP UP BUT THE
IDEA THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
CONSTITUTION PROTECTED RIGHT TO
ENGAGE IN PRAYER IS VERY
AFFIRMING THAT THE COURT, YOU
KNOW, ISSUED THIS OPINION TODAY
BECAUSE THIS IS EXACTLY THE
RIGHT WAY THAT THE -- THE
CONSTITUTION IS SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT THESE INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS
AND THE RIGHT TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF TO PRAYERS IS
PROTECTED.
IT IS A BIG WIN FOR RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY HERE TODAY.
>> Laura: DAN, ON THE ISSUE OF
ROE.COM A LOT WAS ASKED ABOUT
PATROL FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR
WOMEN WHO WANT ABORTION.
WATCH.
>> Vice President Harris: WHAT
ABOUT THE IDEA OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES, SOME FORM OF VOUCHER
FOR TRAVEL FOR WOMEN SEEKING
ABORTIONS STAY THERE IT IS NOT
LEGAL.
>> Vice President Harris: YOU
ARE ASKING -- MAKING A VERY
IMPORTANT .1 OF THE DETAILS
GOING INTO AND ENSURING THAT
WOMEN HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY TRAVEL WITHOUT
IMPAIRMENT.
I WOULD ARE EXPECTED TO
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
PICKUP ARE.
>> Laura: SHE IS TALK ABOUT
HELPING WOMEN TRAVEL
OUT-OF-STATE LIKE YOURS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BEING SUED BY THE
ACLU.
YOUR ACTION?
>> Attorney General Schmitt: THI
S IS A CULTURE OF DEATH AND NOW
THEY WANT TO GIVE A VOUCHER TO
TAKE LIFE OF A BABY?
THROUGH THIS ENTIRE DISCUSSION
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS, SINCE
ROE V. WADE WAS OVERTURNED, I
HAVE NOT HEARD ONE PERSONAL
THOSE PRESENT ON THE LEFT SAY
ANYTHING THAT SEEMED TO CARE
ABOUT THAT LIFE OF THE BABY.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ONE PERSON SAY
WE WISH EVERY BABY WAS BORN.
WE DON'T SUPPORT ABORTION.
WE JUST SUPPORT CHOICE.
BUT WE CARE ABOUT THE BABIES AS
WELL AS THESE MOTHERS.
I HAVE NOT HEARD A WORD.
THEY TALK ABOUT THESE INNOCENT
BABIES IN THE WOMB AS IF THEY
ARE NOT HUMAN AS IF THEY DON'T
EXIST.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T THINK THE
ARGUMENT TO.
THEY DON'T THINK THE ARGUMENT
BIG.
AND GENERAL SMITH, SENATOR
WARREN WANTS TO CARVE OUT -- ON
FEDERAL LAND FOR ABORTION
PROVIDERS.
DHHS SECRETARY HAVE YOUR SARAH.
>> A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS ON
ANY NUMBER OF OPTIONS THAT CAN
BE OUT THERE.
WE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE A CLOSE
LOOK AS WE MADE A COMMITMENT
SOMETIME AGO AS WE WERE PLAN FOR
WHAT WHATEVER IT MAY FROM THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE WILL LOOK AT EVERY OPTION.
>> IS THIS A POP-UP ABORTION
TEST?
>> I MEAN, LOOK, JUSTICE ALITO
HAD IT RIGHT, THE MINUTE THAT
THE ROE VERSUS WADE DECISION WAS
HANDED OUT, IT WAS ON INCLUSION
COURSE WITH THE CONSTITUTION.
THERE GOT IT RIGHT AFTER 49
YEARS AND RETURNED THIS ISSUE.
BECAME THE FIRST STATE TO
EFFECTIVELY END ABORTION AND WE
NEED TO BE UNAPOLOGETICALLY
PRO-LIFE YEAR.
AND THE IDEA THAT THE LEFT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO COME UP
WITH THESE CRAZY IDEAS, CONTINUE
TO INTIMIDATE JUSTICES.
AND WE GOT TO HAVE WE GOT TO
HAVE HUMANS.
THE JANUARY 6th HEARINGS ARE A
TOTAL JOKE BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
HEARINGS ABOUT CHUCK SCHUMER
ENCOURAGING VIOLENCE BUT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY VIOLATING FEDERAL LAW
PRINTED INTIMIDATE JUSTICES TO
CHANGE THEIR MINDS AND
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT AGAINST
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH THIS IS THIRD
WORLD BANANA.
STUFF BUT THERE'S NO LAW NORMAL
OR RULE.
KREMMEL IT IS AN INTIMIDATION
GAME AND THEY WOULD STOP UNTIL
THEY ARE STOPPED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I WOULD PARKED WE HAVE TO GET TO
THE BREAKING NEWS OUT OF SAN
ANTONIO.
SPEAKING OF THE CULTURE OF
DEATH, ENFORCEMENT IS TELLING
FOLKS THAT AT LEAST 46 MIGRANTS,
46 HAVE BEEN FOUND DEAD IN A
TRACTOR-TRAILER MORE THAN A
DOZEN HOSPITALIZED.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S BEEN THREE
ARRESTS MADE WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US TONIGHT?
>> Lieutenant Governor Patrick:T
HIS IS MORE DEATH ON THE HANDS
OF THE PRESIDENT.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING WORSE,
LAURA, THEN THESE PEOPLE IN THAT
18 WHEELER SUFFOCATING.
THE HEAT GOING TO 130 DEGREES OR
MORE.
TRYING TO CLAIM OUT QUICK
DESPERATELY.
AND THEY DIED.
CULTURE OF DEATH BUT WHETHER IT
IS FENTANYL, THAT THEY ALLOWED
TO COME OVER THE BORDER BECAUSE
HE HAS OPEN BORDERS THAT KILLS
OUR TEENAGERS, WHETHER IT IS
THESE 46 PEOPLE AND MAYBE MORE
CORRECT THOSE ARE IN THE
HOSPITAL, VERY CRITICAL.
AND THE BABIES THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT THE PUBLIC IF EFFORT TO
DATE WITH THIS DECISION HANDED
DOWN, LAURA, IF EVER THIS NATION
NEEDS TO THE CLIENT OUT OF THE
DARKNESS WE ARE IN ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, NOW IS THE TIME
THAT WE ALL SHOULD BE ON OUR
KNEES AND PRAYING.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
>> Lieutenant Governor Patrick:A
ND WE NEED TO PRAY BECAUSE
AMERICA IS IN DARKNESS RIGHT
NO